salut aujourd'hui je suis là mais je
suis pas là en réalité au moment où vous
voyez cette vidéo il est 11 heures du
matin
et moi je suis dans le train pour
amsterdam je vais jouer amsterdam ce
soir donc j'ai préparé la vidéo la juste
que vous voyez ici
hier soir je voulais d'hier si vous avez
regardé la vidéo aujourd'hui il y aurait
un rapport avec quelque chose que j'ai
découvert est une énigme
je vous le dire dans quelques secondes
générique quelques temps sur internet
j'ai découvert un truc un peu
ouf j'ai trouvé génial s'est fait par
les éditions du trésor c'est un livre
d'énigmes qui te permet de gagner un
trésor et je me suis dit les mecs c'est
énorme
ils ont poussé de trucs hyper loin donc
je les ai contactés et je leur ai dit
écoutez si vous voulez je fais une vidéo
sur le projet mais vous vous créez une
énigme pour la chaîne et quand le livre
sortira j'aimerais bien avoir quelques
exemplaires pour l'offrir aux abonnés
ils m'ont dit qu'ils étaient ok et ils
m'ont envoyé tout une énigme que j'ai un
petit peu remixé aussi à ma sauce c'est
une énigme en deux parties c'est pas un
placement de produit ya pas de
partenariat derrière c'est juste un coup
de coeur que j'ai eue pour ça et je suis
très content de vous mettre aujourd'hui
au défi ils ont créé pour la chaîne 2
énigmes une un petit peu plus dans le
calcul et une un peu plus littéraire
quand j'ai vu celle sur le calcul mme
sidibé à temps ils connaissent pas mais
abonnés ça ils vont trop trouvé trop
facilement pour ça je vous recommande de
prendre un papier - crayon pour la
première ou alors de prendre votre
téléphone et de mettre en mode
calculatrice après vous pouvez le faire
de tête mais il ya un bon risque
d'erreur dans ce cas là vous prenez
votre année de naissance
sauf si votre année de naissance et un
palindrome un palindrome c'est quelque
chose qui se lit dans les deux sens
comme bob bob bob bob bob
donc si vous êtes nés en 1991 ou en 2332
déjà ça voudrait dire que youtube existe
toujours et que mes vidéos sont encore
gardés
c'est sympa mais surtout c'est une année
palindrome donc il faut que vous preniez
l'année quelqu'un de haut de ton pote de
votre frère de votre soeur première
étape vous mettez les chiffres de
l'année à l'envers par exemple je suis
né en 1982 donc moi ça donne de 8,9 de
1891 deuxième étape vous souffriez ce
chiffre de votre année de naissance donc
moi je vais faire 1982
moi de 1881 que le résultat soit positif
ou négatif
on s'en fiche on s'en fiche de la
polarité en fait de ce résultat
et pour terminer vous pratiquez une
réduction comme ceux ci une grosse
réduction la réduction c'est
d'additionner les chiffres qui composent
ce nombre jusqu'à temps qu'il ne reste
plus qu'un seul chiffre
par exemple mon résultat à moi c'est
moins 909 mais le mois on s'en fiche
donc c'est 909 et bien ça fait 9 + 0 + 9
ça fait dix-huit le 18 qui encore de
chiffres donc je faire un +8 et ça me
fait neuf
est ce que vous êtes toujours là et bien
voici la dernière étape la dernière
étape c'est que vous allez ajouter à
votre résultat la réduction que vous
venez de faire le nombre d'étapes
convient de faire pour cette première
est libre et c'est la première partie de
l' indice de l'énigme finale je vais
quand même vous donner un petit indice
le résultat ça fait partie de la suite
de fuites bonacci et ça ça fait plaisir
comme un 10 1 disons que si vous êtes
risques et des caf ob vous n'allez pas
aimer ce résultat là allez on passe à la
deuxième énigme qui va vous fournir
également la fin de la solution de
l'énigme globale et ça c'est plus avec
les mots et les lettres
ils ont mélangé la charade et le rébus
de systèmes des charades c'est mon
premier et mon second aimons tous et
c'est exactement ça avec un rébus alors
voici mon premier vous met pas non plus
durant des heures vous avez juste à
mettre pause pour prendre le temps de le
déchiffrer
mon second vous est donné par un rébus
équation le voici même principe que tout
allait remettez pose pour le chercher
aimons tous précède mon second est mon
premier dans une célèbre phrase nemo
technique qu'on m'a souvent répété quand
j'étais à l'école surtout en moins
attention sauf pour nos amis québécois
rrq ont pas la même phrase
mnémotechnique dans ce cas là pour vous
mon tout suit mon second est mon premier
et maintenant la synthèse l'énigme
globale si vous combinez la réponse à la
première énigme celle qui était sur les
chiffres avec la réponse de la deuxième
énigme
alors vous avez trouvé le mot clé final
à quoi il sert le mot-clé finale alors
là pour l'instant il vous sert à rien à
part à vous amuser
je vous donnerai la solution dommage
imagine qu y en a qui pourront pas
s'empêcher de la mettre dans les
commentaires
merci à ceux qui l'auront pas fait de
jouer le jeu évitez de le mettre
si ça vous démange par contre vous
pouvez vous donner des petits indices
entre vous ça c'est beaucoup plus cool
je vous le rappelle c'est pas moi qui ai
créé ces énigmes merci à toute l'équipe
du trésor perdu que j'ai contacté je
trouve leur projet hyper ambitieux et
c'est pour ça que j'ai voulu faire une
vidéo sur eux ils sortent un livre
d'énigmes trésor perdu qu'est une chasse
au trésor en france il ya onze énigmes
qui ont été écrites à un mystérieux
libraires et il ya un vrai petit coffret
avec l'équivalent de cinquante mille
euros à l'intérieur en pièces d'or et en
émeraudes qu'on peut retrouver si on
arrive à résoudre le livre il n'ya pas
un coffret par livre et pour éditer le
livre ils ont créé un kiss kiss bang
bang qui s'arrête le 6 le 6 de ce mois
ci si vous voulez précommander je vous
mets le lien dans la description et ça
vous permettra de le voir un petit peu
moins cher un petit peu avant sa sortie
en librairie et même d'avoir une édition
limitée avec des indices
si ça vous tente aussi j'ai vu qu'il y
en a qui faisait ça il y en a qui se
constitue en équipe pour essayer de
chercher le trésor donc vous pouvez
constituer l'équipe des mandats logement
n'occuperait pas mais mais voilà je vous
le dis si quelqu'un veut veut gérer ça
et c'est de faire une team pour essayer
de trouver le trésor fait les amis le
lien est dans la description vous vous
êtes devant l'écran n'hésitez pas à
liker la vidéo également à vous abonner
et rendez vous demain matin à 11 heures
je vous donnerai en même temps la
solution de charge
sa soeur
k
[Musique]